bro since we're already in a laughing
mood so i was thinking about last
episode last night
you know demented garyvee yeah yeah oh
my god don't even bring it back up dude
i don't think i don't think i've ever
laughed that hard and like just the fact
that i was
having a panic attack at the same time
what is it sexually demanding
it's actually demented
should we explain what we're talking
about just for the people that don't
know
because if you listen to the bonus
episode we play this clip of garyvee
talking to this woman and he's like what
what do you value most in her life and
she's like oh my family he's like
once a day five times a week i want you
to picture someone in your family
getting shot in the face
no no it's fine
i was just thinking about being like
you're interested in real estate
imagine being tied up and getting sucked
off by a thousand people
oh no
[Laughter]
oh no imagine consensually being used by
a group of people
every hole in your body filled
[Music]
who's your favorite celebrity you like
to you like to experiment you like to do
new things right
what about sucking off somebody's spouse
oh man the joke yesterday that we
i think it's honestly the best the
hardest and the hardest
for sure i had to leave yeah because i
couldn't
take it anymore i couldn't hear it
because i was like i couldn't breathe i
felt like i was going to die
[Laughter]
and i the joke was that like he he
actually said that in his tick tock
imagine them getting shot in the face
every day and this girl was like what
sorry the most extreme things you could
say
get someone motivated you like crypto
right imagine you're getting imagine
your balls getting snipped off one by
one
oh damn it oh [ __ ]
imagine being tied up and getting sucked
off repeatedly
by thousands of people consensually
until you literally can't come anymore
oh man
[ __ ] no no we have to to move on
because i'm just gonna keep going
do it please do another one you're
interested in forex trading
picture drowning
[Laughter]
oh my god
should think about drowning right now
right now think about drowning
oh my god you're interested in real
estate right
okay think about being a burn victim
it's like why
holy [ __ ] yeah i was just crying
laughing
because i went to get mcdonald's last
night driving home
like what if he was sexually demanded
i want you to picture me tied up you do
whatever you want to me
what would you do what would you do tell
me what would you do
humiliate me perhaps
tell me i have a really small penis in
front of this large room what would you
do
holy [ __ ] oh my god this is a two day
bit man they should be tied up right now
would you smack my dick around
[Laughter]
she picks her drowning
okay so you want to trade corn futures
picture farting in my mouth
oh my god oh god i don't know where you
go from here
that's too good man i'm really thankful
for garyvee honestly
sam alexa and the best part about that
was he deleted that tick tock i know
that's the one time he's got embarrassed
yeah he got he got i think he got a
decent amount of heat from that
[Laughter]
who would have thought man there was
something going on
we've laughed so hard what'd you say i
said who would have thought telling one
of his fans
to picture her family getting shot in
the face every day
too he's like you know what i do i wake
up every day i go in the shower and i
picture
my family dying
imagine being one of the like many
12 year olds scrolling that app and just
seeing that and then just
my family's gonna die one day just the
whole existential crisis hitting like a
train
[Laughter]
nine years old on tick tock imagine your
family getting shot in the face
i love you god damn dude
[ __ ] man i have a piece of like shrapnel
in my eye
are you good no no no
uh gary i gotta be on a figure you dude
what is this thing you put in my eyebrow
it's making me talk english
oh [ __ ] me [ __ ] off so you're interested
in getting into angel investing okay
picture your eyes being plucked out by a
buzzard
i can picture it seriously
what is going on what is in my eye
something from these damn chairs
probably ah
hold on can we get the medic in here
i need to go to med bay you guys didn't
see it but garyvee has infected my eye
for
laughing too much and talking [ __ ] yeah
he cursed us he must have he must have
his ears were burning
yeah he's like i'm gonna make your eyes
burn [ __ ] yeah
you literally was like picture one of
your eyes not working
now never talk about me again
um i'm just gonna close this eye okay is
that weird for you no
i don't care all right as long as you're
fine with it you look like a fetty wap
look like a fatty [ __ ] you look like
fetty wap because i got one eye shut
yeah okay excuse me
um god man garyvee are so sexually
demented that you do this to me
imagine me busting a nut in your eye
permanently yep
you think i could read one of these
books with one of my eyes open
that makes no sense
[Laughter]
i'm so messed up from this
whatever is in my eyeball dude this is
crazy
i think something got in there and
scratched your eye maybe no it's like in
it's like a hard piece of crust in there
i can feel it
me and him are not getting along i know
it's a man because
only a young childish boy crust would do
this to me
during such an important moment such as
my job
do you want to just take a break until
you can get it out
no i want the show must go on i want a
podcast man i want a pod dude
i want a pod i have good things to say i
want a pod
i want a pod all right maybe if we read
an excerpt
from this book it can help get us back
on track
the shape of space this is the shape of
space this new science fiction in
a grand old tradition larry niven wrote
this book
i'm like i was just imagining opening
this and something just flies out
and into your other eyes
gary
all right first of all there's this
there's this epilogue here which is this
first sentence is such a self-suck
the shape of larry niven's worlds is
unique get over yourself dude
you definitely wrote this about yourself
and new thoughtfulness yeah
all right y'all wanna know about um the
shape of space
is this a classic or something it's got
a cool cover
yeah it's got a cool cover i think
i'm sure they saw us coming the alien
technologies officer persisted
see that ring sir silvery image of the
enemy ship almost
filled the viewer it showed as a broad
wide ring
encircling a cylindrical access is a
[ __ ] ring
yeah probably they never saw us coming
[Music]
of course i see it said the captain it
was rotating when we first picked them
up
all right i don't care about this story
this is a tmg book club
yeah i'm already bored
you